what exactly
is the purpose of the higgs and and
what other particles have they found
since they discovered the higgs
well the higgs is is it's a very unique
particle it's the only one
of its kind that has certain certain
properties of
what are called spin and and and its
mass
and it it is it's you know in a simple
way
uh we understand that it's necessary for
particles having mass for them actually
having mass that the theory
itself in quantum field theory
is is a great theory for particles that
uh are
without any mass the way they interact
but in order to
essentially explain certain
mathematical aspects of it you need
something like a higgs particle you need
a particle that has the properties of
higgs
mathematically to have the theory work
out to have the theory work out
and have masses and things like that
you know there's a lot of analogies
people make and
you know uh some of them are better than
others but
you know the one that's most often used
is is the idea that
you know the higgs is this field it's a
it's a it's a field
that permeates everything and particles
moving
through the field get mass i mean
the simple analogy being you know
throwing apart throwing a ball through
the air
versus throwing it you know trying to
push it through water or molasses
you know that um that the different
the the the the the medium
that things move through determine its
mass
so the higgs is like the medium
the higgs is a medium so the higgs is
you know fundamentally the higgs is
something
we call a field and you know what we
believe
is that in the very very early universe
for you know
uh right after you know the big bang
in some sense this field turned on
you know that suddenly this field turned
on or it was created in these early at
this early stage
and uh particles obtained you know
attained mass and you know began to have
the interactions that we know
um so the higgs is a field what we know
is that
in a field you know when you combine
these particles you can excite the field
and it i it manifests itself as a
particle
coming off um and so that's what the
higgs
boson is the higgs when they see the
higgs particle
it's a perturbation in the higgs field
that when we
we combine these things at such
incredibly high energies
and it creates a disturbance in the
higgs field
that we see as the higgs particle as the
higgs boson
so are there is there any way or are
there any theories
that suggest that there could be like
dimensions that we can't even perceive
with our senses
oh yeah yeah i mean we can't perceive
with our senses more than
you know right four i mean you know the
three
physical i mean the three space
dimensions in one time dimensions so yes
so yes so that is the question i mean
all these
ideas i mean many of these ideas well
certainly string theory
uh posits more dimensions
um you know this is this question of
multiverses is do
do multiverses correspond to more
dimensions
and you know there's various theories
about you know why
don't we see them uh you know is it
possible that there are these dimensions
but somehow they're
they're all crunched up so beyond our
dimensions they're crunched up and
they're so tiny
that we can't see them they're folded on
each into each other
but um yes i mean we you know we we
don't see these dimensions
uh clearly in in in our normal
activity but there are
theories about how if they exist there
might be
they might be manifested okay and
um i mean again just to give you an
example of what this could mean
you know it would mean
essentially it would be a bizarre
phenomena
where something might just appear so one
of the
classical examples is if you think of
if you think of the fact that suppose
you lived in a
you know on a piece of paper suppose we
lived in two dimensions
so a piece of paper is just two
dimensions um
and you know you you walk around you're
just on the paper you can't see above or
you can't see below so all you can see
is what's in the paper in the plane of
the paper and now
suppose there is another dimension
you're not aware of it
but there is another dimension and some
ball
you know comes in and enters your
universe
um well what would you see you would see
you know when it first touches you'd
suddenly see it's a spot
and then if it's a sphere you know you'd
see it expand
and as it goes through it you know and
passes through the spot would get bigger
and bigger and then it would get smaller
and smaller and then it would disappear
right and so it would be this phenomena
that you would not be able to explain
with our nor with your normal theories
of you know you've never seen anything
like this suddenly something
appeared and disappeared
um and that would be evidence of
something
you know possible evidence of something
from another dimension
so um you know that's in a
sort of a one simple way to imagine what
what does this mean what
you know what would it be if there's
another dimension and how could we
detect it
and so we look for strange phenomena
like that
that we couldn't that doesn't fit into
our theory but might fit into
how it would work if it was um you know
if it was coming from another dimension
right it's not something that you could
explain with just shapes
that's right you couldn't or you know
just like you know forces that we know
and things like that so
so you know evidence yeah of other
dimensions would be
really weird phenomena you know is there
any weird phenomena that sticks out
that that people have that we've found
in the past
decade or so that hints to anything like
this
not that i know of no i mean no no no no
like sudden appearances of a ufo or
things like that
so um no i mean that's but that's what
they're looking for is they're looking
for things
that don't you know that don't follow
the normal rules of physics but might
uh follow you know might be explainable
in terms of some of these other theories
and there are other theories that do
explain these and
and you know using other ideas and
multi-dimensions and things they can try
to explain
some of some of the
you know missing understanding
in cosmology but that you know
there's not enough there's nothing
that's definitive for sure
um so yeah what particles have been
found besides
the boson the higgs boson well
your documentary well there's there's
have been no new particles i mean uh
i mean there's no you know there's um
you know no fundamental new particles i
mean there's certain variations of
things
um certain things that have certain
properties that
you know we didn't expect but in terms
of
anything beyond the standard model
which is the quarks that we know the
electrons the muons the neutrinos
they have not found a new particle that
doesn't fit into this paradigm
so you know that begs the question is it
um is the theory wrong um or
is it just that we don't have enough
energy because
you know the the the problem is these
theories they don't really predict
definitively what the masses of these
particles are
um we had a certain idea of what the
mass of the higgs should be around
what it should be um but um
you know it's a it's a it's a it's
always a question are we at the highest
are we because we know that you need
higher energies to find these particles
i mean that they
they they uh that's one of the reasons
we don't see them is that they
they uh they don't exist normally
they're not stable
i mean even the higgs boson it doesn't
it doesn't last we don't really
even see the higgs the higgs almost
immediately decays
into other things but our theory
predicts
what it should do and that's what they
find
so the
you know the general the idea still is
that for many people they think that
we should make we need even more
powerful accelerators we need to
get to higher energies um but of course
that
you know the question is well how high
and you know
it's very expensive and technologically
difficult but
there are uh efforts now to build a
already to build a successor to build a
successor to the lhc
really um yeah i mean there's a there's
what was something like that look like
well again you could do it could either
be a big ring another ring
even bigger or um the other alternative
is
a a linear collider where you basically
you have things that you know are
originated at two ends
and you just accelerate them right to
each other and bang them together
and so there are proposals um
in asia and there's a proposal at cern
but these are you know 20 30-year plans
so
the lic itself is still you know very
active they actually have just
upgraded they're in the middle of a big
upgrade
so they already have the they're going
to have the capability to go to higher
energies
and they keep improving their optics in
a sense
you know so they're they've also
upgraded they've upgraded both
the ring to get higher energies and more
accuracy and more
more what's called luminosity so you
know these are bunches of
things that come together and you know
the more you can focus them
the more collisions you're going to get
um it's not and that's not just one
proton one proton
these are packets you know of you know
millions and billions
of of uh protons and you know they sort
of
fly through each other and you get a
certain number of collisions and so of
course if you can
focus it more you'll get more collisions
so they can
they're improving that they're improving
their detectors
you know their ability to detect things
and then they're also starting to lay
the groundwork for what could be the
next
um the next generation of things
is